hallo mein name ist programm wir spielen
heute ein spiel wo es die meisten
wahrscheinlich wieder sagen auch nicht
schon wieder mal war doch damit spielen
wie der sesamstraße findest du jede
menge überraschungen
ja wir sind wieder bei der sesamstraße
und da gibt es da wenig einige sachen
die wir wohl anscheinend nicht gemacht
haben ich guck mal hier auf die da
passiert glaube ich gerade gar nicht mir
wurde gesagt dass ich viele dinge noch
nicht getan haben
das haus hat wissen wir mittlerweile
alles mir klicken man erstmal auf die
luftballons und schauen ob wir bei den
luftballons junge null grad tanzt er da
schon wieder so komisch du musst einfach
auf die gelbe flagge neben mir klicken
okay ich gehe mal drauf
aber klar
groovy sie total komisch aus irgendwie
okay muss auch alle luftballons
draufklicken und habe ich mich nicht die
ganze zeit eher nicht
nichts passiert leider auf nee nee ich
war das nicht halt aber wir beschäftigen
uns damit den wichtigen dinge im leben
luftballons auf pump mit ernie es kommt
der spaß schon wieder hälfte laufen wie
klicken mal wieder auf spiele und
schauen was man hier mit den keksen so
anstellen kann
niemand nahm nehme ich jetzt diesen keks
und listen erhalten
denn dann müssen wir noch stehen in
regalen und jetzt habe ich es auch schon
wieder fällig oder krümelmonster
ich nehme das mal als ein jahr super wie
viel kann dieses monster essen alter
kann nicht einfach mal auf einiger zeit
zu fressen nein ich spiele nicht noch
eine runde zurück für der karotte was
war da ist wieder das verdi gibt es
leckere sachen zum beispiel gemüse
ich schau mal was ich unten machen kann
und zwar möchte für pferd einen kuchen
okay wir wissen den namen von ihm es
heißt einfach fährt das war wirklich wie
geschmiert ich brauche nach mehreren
jahren halt dein maul und jetzt haben
wir wie viel mehr braucht er denn walter
das ist gerade mega kompliziert wie soll
ich das dann schaffe ich nicht okay hier
einen großen kuchen geht es zurück
werden hier geht's zu den fotos guck mal
hier sind fotos von von pferd und immer
wenn du denkst es geht nicht immer von
den fotos kommt auf einmal fährt daher
und haut noch mal so übel ist das ding
raus hier sehen wir fährt beim einkaufen
hier sehen wir fährt beim
die toilette beobachten hier ist mir
fährt mit wir haben hier ein pferd und
wir haben hier ein pferd aber dieses
pferd ist eindeutig kula wir sehen wir
fährt verkleidet als wäre elvis presley
hier sehen wir fährt beim monat vor 3000
zuschauern hier sehen wir fährt mit der
großen liebe und dass mehr bilder ins
lager der frosch möchte über die teiche
seiner freunde die freundin von
forschers richtig süß schnell dahin und
jetzt schnell zu einigen schnell hier
hin so schnell montieren und letzte ihr
über und jetzt sagt das ganz normal
springt einmal hierhin hierhin hierhin
und er kann auch schon längst
rüberspringen der kommt doch vorhin
schon und die entfernung kann natürlich
rüber springen ja freundlich wird dann
sagen das ist das auch
ich glaube mir hat jemand geklingelt
weil ich bin extra gerade nach unten
gelaufen weil ich dachte dass jemand
geklingelt hat es war aber in game
wenn es euch gefallen hat mir die
schlagen halt doch einfach mal
ich würde mich darüber freuen wenn ihr
das video mit einer positiven bewertung
bewertet denn das ist auf jeden fall der
grund warum polemisch dann leider nicht
ökologie ist gestern nach umgefallen ich
lag im bett und irgendwie stehen hier
sind auf einmal hier so runter im
knallvollen hin und ich lieg im panel
krieg vollem herzen bedenkenlose jahr
geliefert